[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
المظاهرات في باريس ومدن فرنسيه اخرى
تتجدد احتجاجا على تصديق ماكرون على قانون
التقاعد دون تصويت برلماني وقوه الامن
تعتقل اكثر من 300 شخص في حين تتقدم احزاب
معارضه اليوم بعارضه لحجب الثقه عن
الحكومه
واشنطن تتعهد باستمرار نشاط مسيراتها فوق
البحر الاسود وتتحدث عن مسارات بديله
لتفادي المقاتلات الروسيه وبيانات
الملاحيه تظهر اقلاع طائره استطلاع
امريكيه جديده في اتجاه غرب البحر الاسود
في حين تتمسك موسكو بمراقبه المسيرات في
اجوائها وتقول ان التناغم مع الامريكيين
خطا رغم الحاجه لمواصله الاتصالات
العسكريه معهم
محكمه اسلام بادي العليا تعلق تنفيذ امر
جلب رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق وزعيم
حزب انصاف عمران خان قبل يوم من مثوله
امام القضاء بتهمه تتعلق بمخالفه قانونيه
بينما يسعى خان للحصول على حمايه قضائيه
من محكمه لاهور العليا للحيلوله دون
اعتقاله من قبل الشرطه
نيوزيلندا تعلن حضره تطبيقي تيك توك
الصيني على الاجهزه التي يمكنها الوصول
الى شبكه الانترنت التابعه للبرلمان
والرئيس التنفيذي للدائره البرلمانيه يقول
ان الحضره جاء بسبب مخاوف امنيه
وسيطبق بحلول نهايه الشهر الجاري الى
اللقاء